what are your what's your take on this
weekend you got glover fighting um yuri
yeah um
you're you've been big on your i love
you yeah he's so why are you so
he's such a he's a freak athlete he's
just a freak athlete he has experience i
don't care about looks what's his uh
what's his um
now you you're no i don't you like weird
right it's weird though all right you
like i'm glad he's not out of shape no
you i'm sorry sir but without his face
you are taken you are you have a bias
you have a bias to good looking tall
guys or generally good looking you fell
in love with conor because he looked
good no no i fell in love with
chronicles you liked his style and
everything else i like that he won right
because we can't with yuri he's won so
many like you can't co-sign he has one
[ __ ] load and he's so creative with the
way he fights he's just so honest
unorthodox yeah what's his what's his
what he came from a kickboxing thing
first or what he he's weird because he
was at the that super well show i did
with dc he's thin man he's not a big guy
he's he's tall but he's i love him you
say he's thin
he's pretty big no no no he's thin for a
205
okay yeah like he he he looks as thin as
almost like a izzy like he's a thin guy
he's not really big really
he was in you know he wasn't in camp or
anything i was like oh he's a thin dude
what would you say he weighs [ __ ] i
don't know the mate
220
i don't know if maybe 220 you saw mark
two yeah yeah 215 maybe he didn't look
like you know he might guess yeah he did
215 18. no yeah he does he have big
hands big heads sometimes yeah their
bone structure you notice when i saw him
and i i saw the hair and i go that's
your i didn't want to be like hello yuri
because i'm like what if it's not i'm
like oh i thought you were i don't know
if it was him either because he was so
like smaller than i thought i was like
he just looked to kind of blend in but
like he is a very handsome guy you know
and then the producer mayor was like hey
yary from ufc i'm like that is him wow
because glover's thick yeah like there's
some 205 which are big boys man yeah um
but yeah like there were some training
sizes in his strength
really really nice guy yeah and and so
against clover you said it's get done
first two i mean i'm sorry yuri has to
get done first two years otherwise
clover or the old if global starts
getting them down taking wearing them
out it's gonna get rough for you yeah
because you're a vet yeah and he's a
good wrestler you said that right
phenomenal wrestler grappler his jiu
jitsu i don't know why it's underrated
but it's insane yeah and for a year that
could be probably also won't be quitting
at any time soon no you're not going to
break all over yeah yeah but again
clover's older here he's you know the
young lion it's so incredible that
glover was able to do that though nuts
like it's getting dominated by come on
[ __ ] jon jones and you bounce back
yeah nuts
so it's tough if you you know i'm such a
glover fan and that his story's so great
so you want to see him win but same time
new blood's not bad and here he has that
style that he can market you know so if
you're the ufc you're probably hoping
yuri wins because it's easier to market
there's new blood you know what's going
on with ghost system right now
fighting heavyweight he's fighting
heavyweights he's older he's out of the
race yeah because i
mean you know
pretty one-sided fight
so it's almost like there's a hot spot
he must be feeling he must be feeling
like
the he could go back to 205 and get that
belt well he went to back 205 because he
was going to go to heavyweight fight ben
rothwell rothwell got cut because he
wanted more money so then now he's back
at 205 fighting
uh krylov which is a great fight yeah
really good fight are you uh
yeah that's
he's a monster what one do you have any
inside info on when jon jones is going
to fight if he's doing that the end of
the year
yeah because he's waiting for stephen
apparently they came out to the end of
the year it's kind of a bummer but yeah